40 ans que la verrière la plus petite
commune de l'agglomération n'avait pas
connu de nouvelles constructions et
celles qui vont venir vont être
importantes à commencer par 82 logements
31 maisons de ville et 51 logements
collectifs en accession sociale ou aider
prévu fin 2013 l'opérateur accompagne
les familles en cas de difficultés mais
les accompagnent aussi dans la démarche
d'accession ce qui rend possible que
cette opération bénéficie au verrière
roi parce qu'il est évidemment ils ont
des faibles ressources un montage qui
permettra aux familles de bénéficier
d'une TVA à 7% et donc d'un prix de
vente en dessous de la moyenne aux
alentours de 2850 euros le mètre carré
un premier pas dans l'aménagement de
l'écoquartier des becanes au moins 1500
logements prévus sur des terrains de 40
hectares situés non loin de la voie
ferrée il y a plusieurs parcs qui ont
été faits pour être tout à fait francs
le premier c'est la mise en place de
toutes les instances de travail et de
concertation avec l'État à la région
Conseil Général l'établissement public
Paris Saclay la communauté
d'agglomération ça va de et la ville
dont on s'est réunit à plusieurs
reprises sous l'égide du sous-préfet du
président de la communauté avec
l'agglomération et de moi-même et puis
nous travaillons maintenant à
concrètement à l'élaboration du projet
en désignant les équipes de maîtrise
d'oeuvre une opération immobilière dans
laquelle s'inscriront également des
commerces l'idée est aussi de
désenclaver les abords de la gare et de
doubler le ponchouleur de tous ces
sujets les verrou pourront discuter avec
l'équipe municipale qui prévoit des
rencontres entre le 12 et le 25 novembre